[Music]
I have three puzzles here it's just him
yes yes it's Jazz no we're gonna go but
suddenly you know there's like some kind
of some kind of triangle so along the
place okay no okay we're no warning I'm
not the fastest so here is the first one
okay
okay so F2 check yeah I Rook 86 F2 PNG
tutor Rook takes G3 Knight H3 qh100 wow
yeah I think I have sold this already
like F2 is the answer
um actually actually I didn't have time
to calculate King takes F2 which looks
uh I mean at the very least I can just
take on D3 and then F1 and I'm much
really ahead and and there is also a
gift to Indian so it's just Checkmate
but of course the point is after look it
doesn't matter which hook takes an F2
then that is Queen G2 check followed by
another tree check and it looks up one
Checkmate how are Rook G1 rupees okay
currently blind all right your 10
seconds is up 100 yeah I just got it
while I was singing briefly yeah so it's
obviously off two and then uh Queen G2
90 strain Rook F1
wow okay so you're I mean there's also
Rook up takes G2 the same thing yeah
yeah I mean workout takes after Queen
you two worksheet tonight usually King
H1 and then virtue one or two ones babe
but yeah
likes to play and win or what yes I like
to play away
thanks
I don't know because I didn't find the
meat so damn
oh you're good I'll make a mover 9ito
yeah unfortunately the move is not 92.
yes I think I'm gonna go find me F2 Rook
take oh F2 I need that warm up can we
start again
yeah yeah I need the warmer
um
don't think it's a mate
yeah no I don't
all dead
um the correct move is actually F2
yeah
and then oh wow like this
somehow it's unusual pattern but it's
really cool no exactly
it's so easy
yeah I don't think I'll be much easier
than this okay
I get the warm up yep 10 seconds all
right I did see this one but um
yeah that's pretty straightforward I
think
yeah that's I mean it's obviously uh
Bishop D2 King A5 or K3 Bishop A4 Queen
takes B7
it is not it's not I'll give you a
second try
really and also five seconds if you want
to look at 40. no I I don't need to I
didn't ah because there's there's a rook
G3 truck that I missed this is true um
okay just give me one side let me think
about this
um yeah I knew it wouldn't be that easy
foreign
okay okay yeah I would I would have had
a thing for like a couple of minutes to
get that that's that's that's actually
pretty tricky
yeah I think I found it
all right
so your final answer is Bishop T2 if
that's correct
it is not Bishop D2
no
not Bishop D2
huh
oh yeah
okay let me try again I know the
position is
Kai's these are hard okay
okay
this one is going to be more
of course
um
now the thing is I want to play I'm not
saying it's in the final answer but I
want to play Bishop D2 with the idea
group a free check and followed by B3
Checkmate but after that that is Rook G3
and um
I can't see an answer I mean the
solution so perhaps I could somehow you
know make sure that the wrong I mean The
Rook on the
first rank like would it get in that way
let's say so I'm thinking about Queen F3
right now I'm not sure which Optics and
it's and only the ending some D2 so that
there is no Rook G3
and uh yeah it looks good but I need to
I need to make sure it's uh
because that's like Queen of three there
is
yeah a little bit tricky but um
I must must be losing because it drops
the queen on this one so yeah okay I
would stay with queen of three in the
first move and after Bishop takes the
premium detail it's for sure that mine
align and the Beautiful One yeah yeah
you're you're nailing this one
ah okay okay I think um I think I this
one I I have I think it's probably
Community First and then she did so
because the bishop D2 there is group G3
so the quick g3g or queen F3 Bishop
little limiting
okay nesting maybe better because then I
just deflect the bishop as well
yeah Queen F3 Bishop of three Bishop yes
that's the one perfect yeah Queen 03 was
the character yeah
I guess Bishop D2
King J5 or K3 chip
unfortunately Bishop D2 doesn't work
because of virtue G3 Arc G3 so Queen F3
first yes okay Queen of the reverse yeah
perfect
Queen takes E2 either
nope
I'm allowed to get pins oh okay three
check me takes 8 30 Bishop D2 awesome
very close takes me to Queen xito it's
not meat I'm not quite it is a queen ah
oh it's a queen mode
oh Queen Esther yeah it's Queen F3 all
right Bishop take five after Bishop D2
uh yeah yes exactly
wow
yeah yeah that's clearly what this is
clearly the training that I need there
yeah Queen Esther is insane
[Music]
one all right one more like ten more
okay let's have more I need to redeem
myself 10 seconds
uh oh my gosh I did this uh exercise
like before
because you know in Polish national team
we had to like uh exercises we had to do
like uh 20 of them I think in a month
and this one was one of them and I
spotted it actually
and uh yeah but I think Ruby it follows
I mean Bishop takes by Queen G6 is uh
it wins oh that's
yeah it wins because of that Mission
Texas yeah
yeah again like the second one I'm
pretty sure it's obvious I'm pretty sure
that it is
Rook 2 EA Bishop takes EA Queen G6 takes
Knight G6 and Bishop C4
perfect okay
oh
okay
yeah I guess it's okay Queen G6
yeah okay attribute creature six yep
perfect
all right
foreign
Bishop takes Queen Knight G6 engine
Bishop C4 completely correct if at least
I got one correca
so many puzzles like I don't like
sounding puzzles at all uh I mean I mean
I don't like doing it but um yeah but I
was also also I mean nine of course I
used to eat and and sometimes he'll do
yeah the second one's quite tricky if
you don't know that it's hard you'll
never get it did anybody get the second
one the second and third is much easier
than the first time out for me but I'm
curious from the other players who who
else will stumble at the person well
thank you so much for participating Yeah
well yeah I wanted more after having two
mistakes
[Music]
foreign
[Music]